joining us now she is the host of the
Ingram angle you see her every weeknight
taking shots at me at 950 950 900 Ingram
good to see you by the way Congrats
I've not really said this publicly but
but I've said it privately the show's
been such a big hit congratulations to
you you're so awesome
we're so glad you're on board let's make
you a broad picture explanation how you
see what you see going on and what
should be happening and in terms of what
the president in terms of his handling
of it all
yeah I think let's start with the staff
shake ups and you hear the other
networks and the usual suspects going
wow this is all this to moult's you know
all these departures from the
administration and they have their big
Scrolls of names and so forth they're
trying to create this appearance Sean of
complete chaos on the White House the
president is untethered to any real
reality it's ridiculous what he's doing
is what he should be doing namely
getting the people in place 13 months
into this who are gonna support his
agenda of course they're gonna question
when that's appropriate but support is
agenda advanced it especially going into
these mid term waters which are going to
be very choppy for the Republicans that
means someone like a Bolton although
he's probably more of a neoconservative
than I am is more interventionist
probably than I am
Bolton is someone who's aggressive he's
not going to go serve the president
right in his agenda absolutely and the
idea that the president's gonna take
orders from John bolt it's ridiculous I
mean he didn't take orders from you know
from Gary Cohen on the tariffs I mean he
decided to go his own way on that and he
stayed true to the blade if he took one
tweet every night day at night because a
lot of people have told him not to
exactly and I also think Shaun when you
when you look at what's happening now
with the FBI and you know Christopher
ray came out and did that interview with
nightly news on the one hand what he
said was I think it was very helpful to
the president because he said we're not
you know we're not political we're I'm
not being influenced by the president
we're not being told not to pursue
particular investigations that's not
that's not where we are however as
you've been documenting night after
night and I've been and trying to pick
up the baton at 10 o'clock what's
happened is a corrosive
atmosphere at the top that I think is
bled down and that has hurt morale at
the FBI that has hurt credibility and
public confidence that that the upper
echelon of these Intel agencies and the
FBI they're gonna call balls and strikes
they're not going to put their finger on
the scale one way or another if even if
they don't like Trump they like Trump
they like Hillary they don't like
Hillary none of that should have come
into play let me ask you this because
we've been at this a long time one of
your great skills is your strategy she
you think you've seen a lot we can give
economic statistics of Ronald Reagan in
our sleep yeah politically speaking this
Donald Trump is a disrupter an
iconoclast and he is not going to as we
were is his old man he's not gonna
conform into what the media wants him to
conform into being he wouldn't have been
elected if he was that person so the
question is strategically knowing
there's this deep state knowing that
we're now breaking through on on FISA
abuses and a fixed investigation a
Hillary and Special Counsel Moe what
advice would you give him I think it's
important for him to keep his eye on the
prize for him it is the economy a stable
strong foreign policy but number one he
should stick to his campaign promises
and Shawn this is where I'm gonna
continue on this tonight on my show I've
been doing it the last couple of nights
this GOP omnibus bill that you know I
guess he's gonna sign I'm really worried
about that I'm worried about it because
it does not adequately fund it the wall
it's like a little pittance a little
scrap of a fence in it it is not what he
can't I do have some insight on that for
you because I agree with you and I am
like really fun the wall if you want to
get reelected for all the Republicans
but there is other money's as I
understand it that have been
appropriated and will be appropriated
and we'll hear about it in the days to
come
well yeah if we lose the House of
Representatives in November I ain't
gonna get any wall so that's why it was
imperative for him really dominant but
fundamental can ISM so my advice is like
Muller is gonna do what Muller is gonna
do I think you can give great speeches
about how this economy is going to
continue to hum we're gonna take take on
China but you know this is what this is
what's gonna happen we're gonna have a
bit of an uncomfortable moment with
China now because of the tariffs it had
to happen
we had to rebalance trade it had to
happen but on Muller
let Muller do his job give great
speeches about about the importance of a
strong intelligence community ignore the
news media I would ignore the media talk
right to the American people and ignore
Muller how you got elected Sean I think
that's good advice at the end of the day
elections are won based on vision on
prosperity if you've been in office and
on peace and if you keep your promises I
don't think it's any more complicated
now or the noise doesn't matter yeah
safety people want to save safe society
law and order
stop giving breaks to illegal immigrants
stick to your promises and you'll do
just just fine all right Laura
great advice